اعلنت السعوديه عن مشاريع باكثر من 183
مليون ريال لصالح المتضررين من زلزال
تركيا وسوريا جاء ذلك خلال منتدى الرياض
الدولي الانساني وتشمل المشاريع انشاءها
ثلاثه الاف وحده سكنيه للمتضررين من
الزلزال بالاضافه لتوفير خدمات رعايه
الصحيه والمواد الطبيه الاساسيه في
المناطق المنكوبه فضلا عن مشروع خاص
بكفاله الايتام الذين فقدوا ذويهم في
الزلزال بقاله وكيلو الامين العام للامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جرافيس ان
اكثر من 350 مليون نسمه في مختلف الدول
بحاجه لمساعده انسانيه ما يساوي ثلث
البلدان الماهوله حول العالم
اكثر من 350 مليون نسمه حول العالم بحاجه
لمساعده انسانيه هذا يساوي ثلث البلدان
الماهوله نحن بحاجه للمساعده بطرق علميه
وملموسه لانهاء الصراعات وهو ما يتم بجهود
دبلوماسيه واعتقد ان السعوديه بحق هي
واحده من الدول البادله للجهود من منتدى
الرياض الدوليه الانساني ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض تابعنا ونتابع معك منذ الصباح
هذا المنتدى اعلان المشاريع وغيره لكن
ايضا كان هناك عدد من الجلسات النقاشات
الحوارات وكذلك الكلمات المهمه
سواء لوزير الخارجيه السعودي كذلك ايضا
وزير الشؤون الخارجيه السعودي
نعم نايف في الحقيقه في هذا المؤتمر في او
المنتدى في عامه الثالث تشارك منظمات
والجهات العامله مع الامم المتحده بشكل
كبير جدا
وباعلى المستويات منذ الجلسه الاولى التي
شارك فيها كافه المنظمات العامله في الامم
المتحده وكذلك في الجلسات الاخرى التي
تستمر حتى هذه اللحظه في الجلسات
المقابلات والتي تتداول عدد من مواضيع في
عمل هذه المنظمات الانسانيه والاغاثيه
والجهود المبذوله من قبل كافه المنظمات
لاغاثه كافه المتضررين من كافه الاحداث
حول العالم سواء كان الطبيعيه او جراء
الحروب او غيرها اليوم ايضا صباحا كان
هناك كلمات لافته لعدد من المسؤولين
الوزير عادل الجبيل وزير السعودي الذي
شارك في جلسه اليوم قال بان تحدث عن عدد
من ربما تخصص في موضوع التغيرات المناخيه
والكوارث الطبيعيه التي تحدث تحديدا
الفيضانات وغيرها وقالت بانه لابد ان يكون
هناك استجابه عاجله وايضا استباقيه لهذه
الكوارث التي تحدث من قبل هذه المنظمات
كما شدد بان السعوديه داعمه
لعدد ما يقارب 95 مليار على كافه العقود
الماضيه بالاضافه الى وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الذي تحدث بان المساعدات الملموسه
والماديه ليست فقط هي المطلوب في الوقت
الحالي ولكن التنسيق بين هذه المنظمات
لتفادي ايه مشاكل او استعداد لايه كوارث
طبيعيه تحدث كما حدث في الزلزال الاخير في
سوريا
وتركيا بالاضافه الى عدد من الكلمات
المتفرقه
للرؤساء المنظمات المختلفه سواء منظمه
الهجره او رئيس الهجره الصليب الاحمر او
المنظمات المنظمه اللاجئين وغيرها من
المنظمات التابعه للامم المتحده للتحدث كل
عن موضوعه وكل عن الاحتياجات وكل عن
مطالباته
رفع الدعم سواء كان على مستوى المانحين او
حتى على مستوى التنسيق بين الجهات العامله
لغتي المحليه او الاقليميه والدوليه نايف
من منتدى الرياض الدولي الانساني انضم
الينا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
شكرا يا عبد المحسن